Another refinement of associa, of associations that I mentioned, is qualifiers.
Qualifiers are indicated by small rectangles, that are on the sides or
edges of class rectangles. The small rectangles contain the name of
one of the attributes, of that particular class. The attribute within the small
rectangle is the qualifier, that can provide access to, instances
of that particular class. If you were doing a relational database model you
would think of the qualifier as the key, into the set of the instances.
In the leftmost example here, we have bank,
and the account number is the qualifier. Note also that there's some
multiplicity information, that a person can have any number of bank accounts,
for example. On the right, we have the situation with a chessboard and
its squares. How would we identify a particular square? In this case,
we're going to use a pair of attributes, giving the rank and the file of
the particular squares within the chessboard. Notice also that in the chessboard
situation, we have a, a composition. Notice the filled black diamond.